in this video we'll talk about the
respiratory burst this is a high yield
topic for USMLE step one respiratory
burst or oxidative burst is a rapid
release of reactive oxygen species
superoxide ions and many other things
like hydrogen peroxide from phagocytes
so imagine this is a neutrophil which is
engulfing a bacteria after engulfing the
bacteria inside the phagosome there
would be Rapid Release of reactive
oxygen species Ross or reactive oxygen
species helps to eliminate the pathogen
in this video we would try to understand
this in bit more details so these are
some pathogens which are potentially
invaded our body
so obviously the first line of defense
the innate immune cells like macrophages
neutrophils and dendritic cells would
try to engulf these pathogens
so after engulfing the pathogens what
happens is really important
so here we are looking at a portion of
the neutrophil so we are looking at the
phagosome it has engulfed the bacteria
right now
oxygen would be taken in and would be
rapidly converted
to a particular reactive oxygen species
and this is done by the
nadph oxidase enzyme in this process
nadph is oxidized now this enzyme is
super important in a disease context we
would understand it in bit more details
further superoxide dismutase convert it
into hydrogen peroxide hydrogen peroxide
can be converted into hocl
reactive oxygen species by the help of
myeloperoxidase enzyme
in parallel process hydrogen peroxide
can be converted into water which is
literally harmless for the cells or the
bacteria
now hydrogen peroxide can be converted
into water with the help of catalase
sometimes many bacteria which has
catalase can convert or neutralize these
raws into water
in this process glutathione is required
so reduce glutathione gets oxidized
which gets further regenerated by the
help of glutathione reductase enzyme
ultimately these reactive oxygen species
can act on the bacteria and lead to its
destruction
so the question is what reaction
reactive oxygen species is doing to
these bacteria so Ross can lead to lipid
peroxidation lipid peroxidation is
basically attachment of the peroxide
group on the lipid and these free
radicals or the reactive oxygen species
are highly reactive
so it lead to overall disorganization of
the membrane as shown here after that it
can also oxidize several Bonds in the
protein
that leads to structural and functional
alterations of the protein
Ross can also create DNA damage
all of these damages together lead to
the destruction of the bacteria and this
is how the pathogen is eliminated
neutrophils ability to create oxidative
burst is compromised in a disease known
as chronic
granulomatous disease or cgd
in chronic granulomatous disease the
enzyme nadph oxidase which is required
to convert oxygen into the reactive
oxygen species is compromised so nadph
functionality is compromised in this
disease and as a result Ross is not
generated When Ross is absent in that
context phagocytes cannot kill these
pathogen efficiently that's why they
Clump around these pathogen and create a
situation known as granuloma
patients are at high risk of infections
with Catalyst positive species because
Catalyst can convert hydrogen peroxide
into water so species like
staphylococcus aspergillus they can
create a lot of problems
anyway I hope this video was informative
short and useful if you want more videos
and more notes flashcards visit our
Facebook page and Instagram page link is
provided in the description
and please support our Channel with
super tanks you can pay via paytm PayPal
or UPI see you in next video